>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IT'S FUNNY HOW NO ONE REALLY
COVERS "THE BIG STORY."  INSTEAD
THE NEWS MEDIA BRING US MINUTIA
ALL THE TIME.
CART LOADS OF IT.
A MIDDLE AGED PROFESSIONAL
GOLFER HURTS HIS LEG IN A CAR
ACCIDENT AND NETWORKS GO
WALL-TO-WALL.
THEY GAVE HIS CAR CRASH MORE
COVERAGE THAN THEY GAVE THE
BOMBING OF SYRIA, LITERALRY.
THEN A FEW WEEKS LATER SOME
WEIRD FAKE DUCHESS FROM L.A.
GIVES A BORING INTERVIEW TO
OPRAH AND WE STOPPED THE
PRESSES.
THAT'S ALL WE TALKED ABOUT FOR
DAYS.
MEANWHILE, SOMETHING
LEGITIMATELY MOMENTOUS HAPPENS
AND IT'S CRICKETS.
JUST YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE TWO
SITTING MEMBERS OF THE UNITED
STATES SENATE ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY OPPOSED THE ENTIRE
FOUNDATION OF AMERICAN CIVIL
RIGHTS LAW AND THEN PROCEEDED TO
ATTACK THE CORE PRINCIPLE, THE
MAIN PRINCIPLE OF OUR COUNTRY.
SOME PEOPLE ON TWITTER WERE
SHOCKED BY IT BUT OTHERWISE YOU
WOULD NEVER KNOW IT HAPPENED.
BUT IT DID HAPPEN.
TAMMY DUCKWORTH OF MINNESOTA AND
MAZIE HIRONO OF HAWAII PUBLICLY
INFORMED THE WHITE HOUSE UNTIL
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PUTS
MORE PEOPLE THEY LIKE IN
POWERFUL JOBS, THEY WILL REFUSE
TO CONFIRM ANY WHITE NOMINEE.
QUOTE, I'M A NO VOTE ON THE
FLOOR ON ALL NON-DIVERSITY
NOMINEES DUCKWORTH SAID OUT LOUD
WITH CAMERAS ROLLING.
I WILL VOTE FOR RACIAL
MINORITIES AND I WILL VOTE FOR
LGBTQ.
BUT ANYBODY ELSE, I'M NOT VOTING
FOR.
JUST IN CASE YOU MISSED IT OR
UNCLEAR ON THE MEANING,
DUCKWORTH SAID THIS SEVERAL
TIMES AND THEN MAZIE HIRONO
BACKED HER UP.
HERE IS HIRONO YESTERDAY ON
MSNBC.
>> TAMMY'S POSITION IS THAT
UNTIL SHE GETS A COMMITMENT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT THERE WILL
BE MORE DIVERSITY REPRESENTATION
IN THE CABINET AND SENIOR WHITE
HOUSE ADVISER POSITIONS, SHE
WILL NOT VOTE TO CONFIRM ANYONE
WHO DOES NOT REPRESENT
DIVERSITY.
SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT PITTING ONE
DIVERSITY GROUP AGAINST ANOTHER.
I THINK THIS IS A WELL
ARTICULATED FOCUSED POSITION.
AND I AM PREPARED TO JOIN HER IN
THAT.
>>
>> DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
ADEQUATELY RECEPTIVE TO YOUR FOR
MORE DIVERSITY?
>> OBVIOUSLY NOT, OTHERWISE
TAMMY AND I WOULDN'T BE TAKING
OUR POSITION.
BE WE WOULD LIKE THEM TO DO
BETTER.
>> Tucker: TALK ABOUT STOP THE
PRESSES.
HERE YOU HAVE TWO ACTUAL U.S.
SENATORS ANNOUNCING IN PUBLIC
THEY WILL DENY JOBS TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
THAT'S NOT NEWS?
OH, YES, IT IS NEWS.
THOUGH MAZIE HIRONO AND TAMMY
DUCKWORTH MAY NOT REALIZE IT'S
NEWS.
ARE HIRONO AND DUCKWORTH NEITHER
ONE COULD CARRY A DINNER
CONVERSATION.
NOT EVERYONE IN CONGRESS IS
STUPID OR OBLIVIOUS.
CHUCK SCHUMER CERTAINLY ISN'T.
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MISSES NOTHING.
CHUCK SCHUMER HAS SPENT HIS
ENTIRE LIFE TELLING US THATIGH
VOLUME THAT RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IS WRONG WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IT IS.
THEN THIS WEEK TWO OF HIS
COLLEAGUES GO ON TELEVISION AND
DEMAND RACIAL DISCRIMINATION.
WHAT DID CHUCK SCHUMER THINK OF
THAT?
CHUCK SCHUMER DIDN'T SAY A WORD
ABOUT IT.
NO ONE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DID.
THESE ARE MORAL PIGMIES SOME OF
THEM WOULD SELL THEIR KIDS AND
SOME ARE RACE HATERS PROBABLY
AND AGREE WITH IT.
WHATEVER THEIR MOTIVES ARE, THE
FACT THAT THIS HAPPENED IN
PUBLIC AND NO ONE IN POWER SAID
ANYTHING ABOUT IT, AS IT DID,
SEEMS LIKE A TURNING POINT IN
OUR COUNTRY.
SO TO RECAP THE MOST BASIC
PRINCIPLE WE HAVE, IT'S THIS:
ALL AMERICANS HAVE AN
INALIENABLE RIGHT GIVEN BY GOD
GUARANTEED BY THE CONSTITUTION
TO BE JUDGED SOLELY AND
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE BASIS OF WHAT
THEY DO, OF WHAT THEY CHOOSE,
NOT ON THE BASIS OF THEIR RACE
OR THEIR GENES OR WHO THEIR
PARENTS WERE.
PERIOD.
THAT IS THE ENTIRE PROMISE OF
OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S WHY WE ARE DIFFERENT.
IT'S WHY PEOPLE MODIFY HERE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT'S WHY WE ARE A SELF-GOVERNING
REPUBLIC BECAUSE EVERYONE IS
EQUAL.
IT'S ALSO BY THE WAY IN ADDITION
TO EVERYTHING ELSE FEDERAL LAW.
IT'S WRITTEN DOWN.
WHAT MAZIE HIRONO AND TAMMY
DUCKWORTH DID IS NOT SIMPLY
MORALLY REPUGNANT, THOUGH ONCE
AGAIN IT IS MORALLY REPUGNANT
IT'S ILLEGAL.
TITLE OF THE 1964 CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT OPENS THIS WAY, QUOTE:  NO
PERSON IN THE UNITED STATES
SHALL ON THE GROUNDS OF RACE,
COLOR, OR NATIONAL ORIGIN BE
EXCLUDED FROM PARTICIPATION OREN
BE DENIED THE BENEFITS OF OR BE
SUBJECTED TO DISCRIMINATION ANY
PROGRAM OR ACTIVITY RECEIVING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE, END QUOTE.
YOU CANNOT DENY AN AMERICAN A
FEDERAL JOB BECAUSE OF HIS RACE.
THAT IS AGAINST THE LAW.
IT HAS BEEN AGAINST THE LAW FOR
NEARLY 60 YEARS.
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN
GOVERNMENT HIRING IS A CRIME.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THAT BEFORE.
IT'S ON THE WALL OF EVERY BREAK
ROOM IN EVERY OFFICE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IN FACT, THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
MAY BE THE MOST FAMOUS LAW THAT
WE HAVE.
BUT, THEN, AS NOW, MANY
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS OPPOSED IT.
CRITICAL RACE THOSH IS NOT A NEW
IDEA DESPITE WHAT THEY TELL YOU.
IN 1964, A THIRD OF SENATE
DEMOCRATS VOTED AGAINST THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
AND ONE OF THOSE WHO DID WAS A
MAN CALLED ROBERT BYRD.
BYRD WAS A STRIDENT SUPPORTER OF
EQUITY OR AS IT WAS CALLED AT
THE TIME JIM CROW.
IN 1944, AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
SECOND WORLD WAR, ROBERT BYRD
WROTE A LETTER TO THEODORE BILL
BOW, A FELLOW DEMOCRAT WHO
REPRESENTED MISSISSIPPI IN THE
SENATE.
BYRD WAS UPSET THAT THE
ROOSEVELT ADMINISTRATION WAS
GIVING FEDERAL JOBS TO PEOPLE
WITH THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
ROBERT BYRD WAS THE TAMMY
DUCKWORTH OF HIS DAY.
QUOTE:  I SHALL NEVER FIGHT IN
THE ARMED FORCES WITH A NEGRO BY
MY SIDE THE, BYRD WROTE
AMAZINGLY.
RATHER I SHOULD I DO A THOUSAND
ISN'T A TIMES OLD GLORY THAN SEE
OUR BELOVED LAND OF OURS BELOVED
RACE AMONG GULLS THROW BACK TO
THE FROM THE WILD.
THAT'S REAL.
ROBERT BYRD WROTE THAT AT THE
TIME HE DID WRITE IT, BYRD WAS
WORKING AS A RECRUITER FOR THE
KU KLUX KLAN VERY MUCH THE YALE
UNIVERSITY OF THE TIME.
THE SOURCE OF SO MUCH POISON IN
OUR SOCIETY.
TWO YEARS LATER, BYRD WROTE TO A
WELL KNOWN CRITICAL RACE
THEORIST CALLED JOEL BASKIN WHO
AT THE TIME SERVING AS THE GRAND
WIZARD OF THEIR BELOVED
ORGANIZATION.
QUOTE THE CLAN IS NEEDED TODAY
AS NEVER BEFORE ROBERT BYRD
WROTE AND I'M ANXIOUS TO SEE
REBIRTH IN WEST VIRGINIA.
IT'S NECESSARY THAT THE CLAN BE
PROMOTED IMMEDIATELY AND EVERY
STATE OF THE UNION.
WILL YOU PLEASE INFORM ME AS TO
THE POSSIBILITIES OF REBUILDING
THE CLAN REALM OF WEST VIRGINIA.
END QUOTE.
THAT'S REAL.
ONCE AGAIN.
SHORTLY AFTER HE WROTE THAT
LETTER, ROBERT BYRD ABANDONED
HIS CLAN CAREER IT NEVER PAID
WELL.
INSTEAD HE DECIDED TO RUN FOR
OFFICE AS A DEMOCRAT.
ROBERT BYRD SERVED IN THE
CONGRESS FOR NEARLY 60 YEARS.
WHEN BYRD DIED, DURING BARACK
OBAMA'S FIRST TERM, THE ENTIRE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CAME FORWARD TO SLOBBER
OVER HIS MEMORY, INCLUDING
AMAZINGLY BARACK OBAMA HIMSELF.
IT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
IMAGINE THE UNITED STATES SENATE
WITHOUT ROBERT BYRD, SAID
HILLARY CLINTON.
BYRD WAS NOT JUST ITS LONGEST
SERVING MEMBER HE WAS ITS HEART
AND SOUL FOR MY FIRST DAY IN THE
SENATE, I SOUGHT OUT HIS
GUIDANCE HILLARY CLINTON SAID.
AND OF COURSE SHE DID.
QUOTE, WHILE SOME SIMPLY BORE
WITNESS TO HISTORY REMARKED A
EMOTIONAL NANCY PELOSI ROBERT
BYRD SHAPED AND IT STROVE BUILD
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR US ALL.
BILL CLINTON WENT ON THE
LONGEST.
BIDEN DESCRIBED ROBERT BYRD VERY
CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE ONE OF MY
MENTORS.
HERE IS JOE BIDEN CELEBRATING
WILLIAM SHAKER SPEAR AS HE
MENTOR.
>> WHEN I LEARNED OF HIS DEATH I
WAS ON ANNER RAND FOR PRESIDENT
IN CLEVELAND, AND I SAID, YOU
KNOW, TO PARAPHRASE THE POET, WE
SHALL NOT SEE HIS LIKE AGAIN.
MR. LEADER, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LOOK UPON YOU LIKE AGAIN.
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO ASK GOD TO
BLESS YOU BECAUSE HE ALREADY HAS
AND I KNOW WHERE YOU ARE.
>> Tucker: OH, BUT YOU ARE
THINKING THAT WAS A LONG TIME
AGO AND BIDEN PROBABLY DOESN'T
EVEN REMEMBER THAT WAS WAY BACK
IN THE SUMMER OF 2010.
WHEN PEOPLE JUST DIDN'T KNOW ANY
BETTER.
THEY THOUGHT THE KU KLUX KLAN
WAS SOME KIND OF HARMLESS
FRATERNAL ORGANIZATION LIKE THE
ELKS OR THE ROTARY.
RIGHT.
THEY KNEW.
UNDERNEATH IT ALL THEY NEVER
REALLY DISAGREED WITH THE CORE
IDEA.
ONLY THE COLORS HAVE CHANGED.
THEIR EXISTS IN THE DARKEST
PARTS OF HUMAN NATURE THE
EXTINCT OF FORMER MOB AND ATTACK
PEOPLE FOR HOW THEY WERE BORN.
FEAR OF THE OTHERS IS WHAT
SOCIOLOGY JUSTS CALLED FEAR OF
REVOLUTIONARY BIOLOGY.
WHEREVER IT COMES FROM HOWEVER
YOU DESCRIBE THIS PHENOMENON IT
IS REAL AND A GRAVE THREAT TO
AMERICA.
THIS IS ENORMOUS COMPLEX AND,
YES, DIVERSE SOCIETY.
WE HAVE VERY LITTLE IN COMMON
WITH EACH OTHER APART FROM THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ALL AMERICANS.
350 MILLION PEOPLE LIVE WITHIN
THE BORDERS OF THIS COUNTRY.
MOST OF US CAN'T LEAVE.
SO WE HAVE TO LIVE TOGETHER.
IF YOU WANT AMERICANS TO LIVE
PEACEFULLY WITHOUT HURTING EACH
OTHER, YOU HAVE TO TREAT THEM AS
INDIVIDUALS.
NOT AS MEMBERS OF WARRING
TRIBES.
YOU HAVE TO GUARANTEE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN HAS THE SAME, THE
IDENTICAL OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
AND LIVE AND GO TO SCHOOL.
AS WELL AS THE SAME, THE
IDENTICAL JUDGMENT UNDER THE
LAW.
A QUALITY UNDER THE LAW.
YOU CAN'T JUST ANNOUNCE THAT
AMERICANS OF CERTAIN COLOR CAN'T
HAVE JOBS.
IF YOU DO THAT, THINGS WILL TEND
TO FALL APART VERY QUICKLY.
WE FOUGHT A WAR OVER THIS ONCE
BY THE WAY.
700,000 PEOPLE DIED.
AND IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT
ALL AMERICANS UNDERSTOOD THIS OR
PRETENDED THEY DID.
BUT THEN A NEW GENERATION OF
ROBERT BYRDS TOOK CONTROL OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND DARK AND
PREEMPTIVE FORCES HAVE BEEN
UNLEASHED.
YOU SEE THEM EVERYWHERE.
YOU HARDLY NEED TO BE REMINDED
OF IT, BUT HERE IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE FROM YESTERDAY.
THE NATION MAGAZINE THE FLAGSHIP
PUBLICATION OF THE AMERICAN LEFT
RAN A PIECE WITH THIS TITLE,
QUOTE:  I AM NOT READY TO
REENTER WHITE SOCIETY.
NOW, THIS WAS WRITTEN BY A
HARVARD LAW GRADUATE CALLED
ELLIE, HERE IS THE OPEN QUOTE I
HAVE SAID HERE AND ELSEWHERE
THAT ONE OF THE PRINCIPLE
BENEFITS OF THE PANDEMIC IS HOW
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO EXCLUDE
RACISM AND WHITENESS GENERALLY
FROM MY DAY-TO-DAY LIFE.
OVER THE PAST YEAR I HAVE, OF
COURSE, STILL HAD TO INTERACT
WITH WHITE PEOPLE ON ZOOM OR
WATCH THEM ON TELEVISION OR
WORRY ABOUT WHETHER THEY WOULD
SUCCEED IN REELECTING A WHITE
SUPREMACIST PRESIDENT.
BUT WHITE PEOPLE AREN'T ALL IN
MY FACE ALL THE TIME.
I CAN MORE OR LESS ONLY DEAL
WITH WHITENESS WHEN I WANT TO.
WHITE PEOPLE HAVEN'T IMPROVED.
I HAVE JUST BEEN ABLE TO LIMIT
MAY EXPOSURE TO THEM, END QUOTE.
THAT'S SOMEONE WHO WENT TO
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
THAT IS NOT NORMAL AND IT'S NOT
HEALTHY.
IT IS OPEN RACE HATE AND IT'S
THE BEGINNING OF ACTUAL
DESTRUCTION.
AS WITH SENATORS HIRONO AND
DUCKWORTH, NO ONE IN POWER SAID
A WORD ABOUT IT.
SO, NATURALLY, EXHIBITIONS LIKE
THAT ACCELERATE AND BECOME MORE
DANGEROUS.
LAST WEEK A CORPORATE OWNED
WEBSITE CALLED THE ROOT
PUBLISHED A KIND OF TERROR
MANIFESTO WRITTEN BY A "NEW YORK
TIMES" CONTRIBUTOR CALLED DAMON
YOUNG.
>> THE TRACK BEGINS LIKE THIS
QUOTE WHITENESS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS.
IT SHORTENS LIFE EXPECTANCIES IT
POLLUTES AIR, CONSTRUCTS QUILL
LIB BRIM IT DEFICIT STATES
FOREST AND MELTS ICE CAPS
CONSCIOUSNESS AND IT KILLS
PEOPLE.
SO WITH THAT ESTABLISHED THAT
WHITENESS IS THE MOST DANGEROUS
FORCE IN THE WORLD, YOUNG WRITES
THIS QUOTE WHITE SUPREMACY IS A
VIRUS THAT, LIKE OTHER VIRUSES,
WILL NOT DIE UNTIL THERE ARE NO
BODIES LEFT FOR IT TO INFECT.
WHICH MEANS THE ONLY WAY TO STOP
IT IS TO LOCATE IT, ISOLATE IT,
EXTRACT IT, AND KILL IT.
END QUOTE.
AND KILL IT.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, WHERE
IS THIS GOING, EXACTLY?
ARE LET